ｳﾌｯ////
(息を吸う音）
楽しい時間になりそうだ、、、
楽しい時間になりそうだな、、、
こんにちわはじめしゃちょーです。
けぇんにちわ はじめしゃちょーです。
皆さんゴキブリのおもちゃを使った動画を
よく観たことあると思います
よく見たことがあると思います
ゴキブリを頭の上にこうやっておとしたり
よくたことあると思います
ちらばせたり、色んなあれがあると思うんですけども
散らばせたり
いろんなアレがあると思うんですけど
結構たくさんのゴキブリのおもちゃを使ってると思うんですよ
結構沢山ゴキブリのおもちゃを使ってると思うんですよ。
結構たくさんのゴキブリのおもちゃを使ってるとおもうんですよ～
100個とか200個…。
100個とか200個
１００個とか
２００個！！
多くても千個くらいかな～？
多くても1000個ぐらいかな～
多くても千個位かなぁ～？
多くても1000個位かなぁ…………
・・・・
・・・
甘い！！！
甘い！！！！！！！！（井戸田かな？）
今日俺は！
今日俺は！！
今日俺はそのゴキブリのきりょっ
今日俺は！！！！！その！！！！！！！！
その！！
そのゴキブリのきりょ・・
ゴキブリのきりょ
ゴキブリのきりょ・・・
あ～噛んじゃった・・
あ～、かんじゃった・・・
そのゴキブリの数の記録を
そのゴキブリの数の記録を！！
おヴヴヴヴヴぇ
ぅおっふぇん！
ぉぇええっ！！
（むせる）
そのゴキブリの数の記録を
そのゴキブリの記録を大きく
そのゴキブリの数の記録を大きく上回る事にしたぁ！！
大きく上回ることにしたぁ！
上回ることにした！！！
はい、
はい！
はい、というわけで
という訳で、
この袋の中にゴキブリが１００匹入っております
この袋の中にゴキブリが100匹入っております
この袋の中にゴキブリが100匹入っています
この袋の中に、ゴキブリが100匹入っております。
１００！
２００！！
３００！！！
４００！！！
５００！６００！！
７００！８００！！９００！！
サンゼ～～～～～ーン！！！！
さんぜぇん！！！
サンゼぇぇぇぇええええーん！！！！！
とりあえず箱から出してみましょうか（袋だよ）
それじゃあ箱から出してみましょうか
とりあえず箱から出してみましょうか。
それじゃ箱から出してみましょうか
ううぇ
うえっ
うえぇ…
うぇっ
うわっこれやべぇな！！
うわこれヤベえな
うわコレやべーな
うわっこれやべぇな！
（袋から出しています…）
（だいぶキモイっすね…）
ぽん！
ぽん
ポン、カっ♪
カン！
カンっ！
ぽん！！
カン！！
カンっ！
ぽんっ！
ぽん！
カンっっ！！
カンっ！！
ぽんっっっっ！！
ぽん
キモっ
きもっ
いやー！きもいっすね！コレ中々！！
いや～！きもいっすねこれ中々！
いやー　キモイっすねこれなかなか
無駄にリアルなんだよなこれ
無駄にリアルなんだよなーコレ
無駄にリアルなんだよなーこれ
無駄にリアルなんだよね～これ！
いや～、これヤバいな、マジでヤベえな、これホントに気持ちわりぃな
いや～これやばいな！
いやーこれやばいな！
これヤバいな
まじでやべぇなコレ！ほんとに気持ちわりぃな！
まじでやべぇなこれ！！
まじでヤべーな　ほんとに気持ちわりーな
ホントに気持ち悪いな！
うわ
うわ！！ひい！　やばい！！
ぅゎあ！　ひぃ！　　やばい！！　うあ！　やばい！！
ひい
うわ！！
ヤバいっ！！、うわっ！！！、ヤバいっ！！！
やばい！！！
ぅぎゃやああああああああーーー！！！！
ああああああああああああああああああ
うぎゃやああああああああーーー！！！！！
待ってこれ凄いよ！
待ってこれすごいよ！
まって！これ！すごいよ！
広がっても広がっても
広がっても広がっても、 ゴキブリが止まらないよ（？）
ゴキブリがとまらないよ！！！
うわ…、待って…、ホントに…、うぇ？
ぅうわあぁあ！
うわ！
ホントに？
ほんとに・・？
うぇ？
うあぁぁぁぁあああ！！　キモイ！！！
うああああ！！キモい！
うわぁ！まって！！
うあ！まって！！
もう待って！無理無理無理無理無理
無理無理無理無理無理（ジョジョかな？）
無理無理無理！！！！
うわ～何これ？
うわぁ何コレ？？
うわぁ…、なにこれなにこれ…
うわあナニコレナニコレ
なんかスゲー気持ち悪いと思ったら
なんかすげぇ気持ち悪いと思ったら
なんかすげー気持ち悪いと思ったら
なんかプラモデルの取り忘れみたいなのがくっついてて
なんかプラモデルの取り忘れみたいなのが
なんかプラモデルの取り忘れみたいなのくっ付いてて
くっついててすごく気持ち悪かったです。
すごい気持ち悪かったです
すごい気持ち悪かったです。
ぷちっ！
プチっｗ
(ぷちっ）
（ボス感あるBGM）
はい！と言うわけで！
はい、というわけでもうすぐターゲットが帰ってくるんですけども、
はい、というわけで
はい！！という訳で
もうすぐターゲットが帰ってくるんですけども、
もうすぐターゲットが帰ってくるんですけども
もうすぐターゲットがけ帰ってくるんですけども～
難しいなあ。
難しいな！
難しいな
どう仕掛けようかなー
どう仕掛けようかなあ
どう仕掛けようかな～？？
ちょっと２パターン考えてまして～、
ちょっと2パターン考えてまして
ちょっと２パターン考えてまして～
ちょっと2パターン考えていまして、
部屋の電気を暗くして、電気をつけた瞬間部屋の周りが全部ゴキブリ作戦か
部屋の電気を暗くして　電気をつけた瞬間
部屋の電気を暗くして、電気をつけた瞬間
部屋の電気を暗くして、電気を付けた瞬間
部屋の周りが全部ゴキブリ作戦か～　、　　　　『キャーーーーーーー！！！』
部屋の周りが全部ゴキブリ作戦か、（きゃあああああああああ）
キャーーーー！！！
もうなんの前触れも無いままいきなり頭からぶっかける作戦の2択なんですけど…
こう、何の前触れもないまま
もう何の前触れもないままいきなり頭からぶっかけるか作戦
もう何の前触れもないまま
いきなり頭からぶっかけるか作戦
いきなり頭からぶっかける作戦か二択なんですけど
の２択なんですけど～、
バタンッ
どっちが良いかな？
どっちが良いかな
どっちが良いかな～？
どっちがいいかな
でもこんなに多いと難しいんすよね逆に
でもこんなに多いと難しいんすよね、
でも、こんなに多いと難しいんすよね、
でもこんなに多いと難しいんすよね 逆に
逆に！！
これだけ数があると、床にあっても完全に怪しいんで
これだけ数があると～
これだけ数があると
床にあっても完全に怪しいんで
床にあっても完全に怪しいんで～
ぶっかけ作戦のほうがいいかなあ
ぶっかけ作戦の方が良いかな～？
ぶっかけ作戦の方がいいかなぁ‥
どっちがいいんだろう？×２
どっちが良いんだろう…、どっちが良いんだろう…
どっちがいいんだろう
部屋が暗ければいいんだけど
部屋が暗ければいいんだけど、、、
部屋が暗ければ良いんだけど‥
部屋が暗ければいいんだけど
入った瞬間多分暗ければ
入った瞬間暗ければたぶんそんなに違和感がない
そんなに違和感はないんですけど・・
そんなに違和感はないんですけど、
多分～？
多分・・・？
多分…
あ！暗いな！！
あー暗いな。
あ！暗いな！
あっ暗いな　OK　いけるな
OKー、イケるな！
おっけ。いけるな。
OKイケるな！！
これは暗いぞ！！　イケるぞ！！
これは暗いぞ！イケるぞ！！
これは暗いぞ　いけるぞ
これは暗いぞ。いけるぞ。
イケる！！！！！！
いける！！！！！
イケルゥ！！！！！！！！！！！！！！
たぶんこの感じでも暗い作戦だといけそうなので～
多分この感じだと暗い作戦でもいけそうなので
多分この感じだと暗闇作戦でもいけそうなので
暗い作戦でもいけそうなので、
部屋を真っ暗にして部屋中にゴキブリを散りばめて、
部屋を真っ暗にして
部屋を真っ暗にして、
部屋を真っ暗にして、部屋中をゴキブリを散りばめて
部屋中をゴキブリをちりばめて！
部屋中をゴキブリをちりばめて
電気をポンとつけたら、部屋中の2000匹のゴキブリに囲まれているドッキリにします
電気をポンと点けたら
電気をポンと付けたら
”部屋中の2000匹のゴキブリに囲まれているドッキリ”にします！！
部屋中が2000匹のゴキブリに囲まれているドッキリ
部屋中が2000匹のゴキブリに囲まれてるドッキリにします（3000じゃないの？）
にします！
でや行こう！！！！！！！！！！！！
では行こう！！！　　　　　　　　　　『ゴンッ！！』
では行こう！！！　『ゴンっ！！』
あ！やべ！
あぁあ！！やべ！
あっヤベっ
あっ　やべ
ほんとに怖い感じにしたい！
ホントに怖い感じにしたい！！
ホントに怖い感じにしたい
バラバラ…。バラバラ…
（ゴキブリ準備中）
コレやべぇな！
コレやべぇな
コレまじでやべぇぞコレ！！
コレまじでやべぇぞコレ！
（準備中）
ねえ、これヤバいホントにきもい
ぅんえっ！
ぅえぇ！
コレやばい！！
やばい！ほんとキモい！！
ほんとキモイ！！
ぽん！
はい。
はい！と言うわけで
はい　というわけで大体完成しました
というわけで大体完成しました
だいたい完成しました！
密集してたり、ちょっと離れてたり
密集してたりちょっと離れてたりする
密集してたり離れてたりする
密集してたり、ちょっと離れてたりする微妙なバランスを考えて色んな場所に配置してみました
微妙なバランスを考えて
微妙なバランスを考えて色んな場所に配置してみました！！
色んな場所に配置してみました！！
いろんな場所に配置してみました
コレで後は！！
これで後は！
これであとは！
部屋を真っ暗にして！
部屋を真っ暗にして
部屋を真っ暗にして彼の帰りを待つだけです
彼の帰りを待つだけです！！
彼の帰りを待つだけです！(ゲス顔)
彼の帰りを待つだけです…！
ピロピロ♪
（怪しげなトランペットのBGM）
ガチャっ（ドアを開ける音）
ガチャっ
ごとっ
ごんっ
ゴトっ
ごそっ
はあ…
なんでこんな暗いの・・・？？
（ざわつくターゲット）
なんでこんなに暗いの？？
なになになに
なになになに・・・？？
えっこれなに？
え？これなに？
えっ　何　何　なに　なに・・・
え？何　なに　　なに　　何？
えっ…？
うぇっ？
ぅぇああああ！！
うゎおおお！！
うおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおああああ
ぅぇああああ！！×２
うゎおおお！！×２
ぅぇああああ！！×３
うゎおおお！×３
ぅぇああああ！！×４
うゎおおお！！×４
ぅぇああああ！！×５　ビックリした！！！
うゎおおおお！！！！！×５　　　　　　ビックリした！！
あっひゃひゃひゃひゃひゃｗｗｗｗｗ（高笑い）
びっくりしたあ
ぅひゃひゃひゃひゃひゃあっｗｗ
うひゃひゃひゃひゃひゃっｗｗｗ
あっ///
今回私が字幕を製作しようとした所
どうやら製作途中の様で、内容があまりにもひどかったです。
もやしもやしと連続で書いていて、消すのに時間がかかり
大変迷惑をしました。コメント欄だけでなく
皆さんには
字幕の製作の時にも、悪質な方がいる事に気付いてほしいです。
恐らく小学生の野郎が書き残したものと思われます。
~ED~
匠、早く！匠早く！
早く！！
早く！
はじめ：早く　はやくはやく
はやくはやく！！
匠：分かった分かった分かった
がちゃっ
うおおおおおおおお
ううぇ！？
うわあ！！
ぅうわあ！！